welcome back uh i i don't like to rush
too much on these videos so i just
wanted to
continue the next one so what we did i
just wrote out everything they tell us
in the problem we figured out x is equal
to y so they must both be 45 degree
angles and since y is opposite to this
angle it must be 45 and since
this angle this angle and this angle are
the same triangle and this one's 45 this
is 90. this must also equal 45.
and what i said is we need to figure out
this green line and i made the claim and
i think you'll believe me that this
green line is the same length of this
line that i just drew this peach line
right
and also what else do we know about this
larger triangle well its hypotenuse is
here its hypotenuse is this magenta line
right there
and let me redraw it here
so the hypotenuse is this magenta line
what's the length of the magenta line
it's 4 plus 8 they gave us that
information
so it's 12
and we want to figure out
we want to figure out this
peach line i'm just redrawing it so that
you know we're
we're clear of all of the uh the mess
this is
right i'm saying this green line is the
same as this piece line and i just
redrew this piece line here
what do we also know about this triangle
well if this angle up here was 45 what's
this angle here
that's also going to be 45 right because
this is these two lines are
perpendicular so this is 45
and we also know this angle x is this
angle here so that's also 45 or you
could figure it out any other way
so there we go
we have a 45 45 90 triangle we know it's
hypotenuse can we figure out the sides
well we know the sides are going to be
equal right because the base angles are
equal or we also know that 45 45 90
triangle the sides are equal in fact you
can even look at the
at the beginning of the book they even
define a 45-45-90 triangle
but we'll work it out just so you see it
kind of worked out without having to
memorize
so x squared
this is just pythagorean theorem plus x
squared is equal to the hypotenuse
squared is equal to 144.
2 x squared is equal to 144
x squared is equal to 72
x is equal to the square root of 72
so what's the square root of 72
square root of 72 is the square root of
36 times 2 which is the same thing the
square root of 36 times
the square root of 2
and what does that turn out to be well
square root of 36 is 6 right
so our answer is
square roots
of two
so that is choice
b
next problem
problem eight
the price of ground coffee bean is d
dollars for eight ounces
so d dollars
for eight
ounces
and each ounce
makes c cups
of brewed coffee
so one ounce
makes
c cups
of brewed coffee in terms of c and d
what is the dollar cost
right d dollars for eight ounces okay in
terms of c and d what is the dollar cost
of the ground coffee beans required to
make one cup
we don't we just want to make one cup
and we say how much does that cost us
okay
so let's see how many cups we can make
with
d dollars okay
so d dollars we would get eight ounces
so
d dollars
we get eight ounces
and then each ounce you get c cups right
one ounce turns into c cups so eight
ounces will turn into eight c cups
eight c cups
but we only want one cup right so we say
you know what we're saying
d dollars is equal to
eight c cups
but we only want one cup so let's divide
both sides of this by 8c
so what are we left with
we're left with
d over 8c dollars is equal to 1 cup
and that is choice a
not too bad huh
next problem
problem number nine
problem
nine
if
ten
over a
is equal to b over 12. what is the value
of a b so this is a straight cross
multiplication
a times b is equal to 10 times 12. so a
b is equal to 10 times 12 which equals
120. we are done 120 is our answer and
if you haven't learned to cross multiply
it's just a quick way you can all when
you see you know two fractions equal
each other you could take the numerator
of the left times the denominator of the
right and that equals the denominator to
the left times the numerator of the
right and how do we know that well we
could just we could do it step by step
you can multiply both sides times a
times a that cancels out you're left
with 10 is equal to
a b over 12 and then you multiply both
sides times 12 you get 120 is equal to a
b
that just skips one step right there
next problem
problem 10.
they give us a little sequence here 150
6. and it keeps going and the sequence
above each term after the first term is
one-fifth of the preceding term what is
the fifth term of the sequence sequence
so one-fifth of the preceding term so
this is so the next term is going to be
one-fifth of this so that's what that's
six-fifths
right i just multiplied one-fifth times
that so the next term is gonna be
one-fifth times this so that's 6 over 25
right 1 over 5
times 6 over right 6 over 5 times 1 over
5 is equal to 6 over 25.
so that is
the fifth term
and you could write as a fraction or you
could write as a decimal i think you'd
get 0.24 if you do it as a decimal
next problem
i'm suspicious that seemed too easy
problem 11.
five points a b c d and e lie on a line
not necessarily in that order
a b
has length 24.
point c is the midpoint of a b so let's
draw this and let's see if we can avoid
messing up
okay
so
let me draw a and b
whoops oh
a
b
so they tell us this is how i do it if i
was taking it taking the test a b is 24.
point c is the midpoint of a b so point
c is right here
and it's the midpoint so this is 12
and this is 12.
so far so good
and point d is the midpoint of ac
so point d is the midpoint of ac so this
distance is six
and this distance is six right it's
getting smaller i should have drawn this
bigger but i think you get what i'm
saying this is point d here in yellow
yellow if the distance between d and e
the distance between d and e so this is
d
and the distance between d and e is five
what is one possible distance between a
and e so we they're essentially saying
where could e be so e could either be
so let me let me blow things up a little
bit
let me
redraw this
and let me focus on a and c because
that's the part that got all scrunched
up
so if this is a
this is a
this is c
this is c and then we they tell us that
d is the midpoint of these two
d is this midpoint
and we figured out that a to c was a to
c was 12 and a to d is six right this
distance is six
which is the same as this distance
that's also six
and then they tell us at the end if the
distance between d and e is five what is
one possible distance between a and e so
we know that e is on this line as well
so there's two places where e could be
e could be
five in this direction it could be here
e could be there
or e could be 5 in this direction
where this is 5.
and this is 5.
so if e is here
what is the distance from a to e
well this distance from a to e is just
going to be one right
you go one to e and then five to d and
that adds up to six
so one possible distance for a e
is six
so it's one the other one is you go six
to d and then you go five to e so the
other possibility is 11.
and so oh this isn't multiple choice you
could fill out either one of those
choices see in the next video